what's your name and what's up bro
thanks bro
so box awesome I love it
that's gonna crush it I'm not money I'm
never taking a dollar I need you need to
be create more context see what you did
there for right there was the 19 year
old douchebag move right you see them
live exhibit exactly what not to do on
social media anyone I love you and we'll
fix it but let me crash their face real
quick what he did there was without
having too much cut see see other people
see this you know and other people in
this crowd who I do have context with I
would do that more because there's a lot
of equity there right
but in weren't just me now we have
already more equity than we did ten
seconds ago because now I know your name
and I loved your hustle there but then
when we came to me I had a recorrect it
because that's existing the right thing
and I love the hustle and you're young
and don't get sad but true money but too
many businesses are treating social
media like ant they just go in and say
buy my [ __ ] and without the context in
I'm gonna pretty girl you've got a
you've got a deem me a little bit here
[ __ ]
somebody said something really smart
that I brought a conference I remember
who they said the deer have shotgun it's
now right that customers now have power
anything that's interesting in its one
way to look at it but I think it's
actually a negative way to look at it
I'm far more interested in thinking that
you know that every customer now is the
most popular girl in high school and
that's how you have to attack it you
can't just go in for the kill on the
first move you know so go ahead man
yeah no problem enjoy